[Music]
we did our first event named how was it
it's good you're looking for reasons for
it not to work instead of the side end
this has to work and I'm going to find
solutions you can't quit as long as you
love it excited it's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I made it this is it right the camper
hotel here in Pittsburgh Pittsburgh
ready to go
and what time is it it is it is 4:40 so
in an hour in two hours in two hours he
talked with her begun this room will be
full of people will be changing lives
I'm excited it's happening the first one
day one we're here Pittsburgh Nina's
organizing she's an organization vote
and we love her you set all this up now
we gotta unpack this gear and make it
all work let's go
so for ten years my action didn't match
my ambition yep now I don't have any
issue I've removed all those I am doing
a very similar thing to what you're
doing but you're well ahead of me on the
back do you have any advice and what's
the thing doing seminars and events and
workshop okay yeah so I would start with
creating content every single day I'm
not doing any video yeah I've done some
but I'm not consistently doing videos
that's part of my social media plan now
so that's what you need like if you want
to be speaking I get all my speaking
stuff from my content it's my YouTube
channel because they see you speaking
hey I like this guy I like his vibe I
like his message I like his energy we
should hire him to come speak at our
event but if they go to your your
account and they're only seen pictures
with maybe great captions and fire
content great but I don't see you
speaking I'm not gonna hire you to speak
same thing with YouTube
I want a 10 minute video every day for
you and you do and screw the editing
don't worry about editing nobody's gonna
hire you because you're a great editor
learn to go make a fire 10 minute
content it doesn't need any editing your
thought leader so all I need you to do
is teach me to think the way that you
think I'll sort of wanted to you you
know people don't hire me as an
underwear model you know like right
right it's a thought leader so I'm
learning to think the way you think so
that's the most important thing we're so
worried about like what camera to use
and what microphone to use and all of
this stuff that doesn't matter it
matters for you're an editor if you're
an editor and you're editing sucks then
that matters if de Meade the
videographer his video suck that matters
if you're a thought leader the only
thing that matters if your thoughts suck
so spend less time editing most people
who are in this field spend week you
spend 20 minutes recording the video and
then five hours edit in it you're
training the wrong skill you should flip
it 5 hours working on your video doing
it again again get better watch it back
see where you stumble do it again again
again and 20 minutes editing it
because your goal as a thought leader is
be able to deliver a message in a
15-second Instagram story - one-minute
video - Tim in a YouTube video - 30
minute eNOS - a four day workshop the
same message huge and crunched down to
nothing and you can play anywhere in
between and the skill that you're
learning of communication will serve you
for life where you this is the plea
before after you met your spouse and
also how important is it to have a
significant other on the same pages
you've been born in the same direction
for YouTube being so focused on what you
do every day versus what she or he may
want to do yeah so I've been this
discipline for awhile before Nina it's
been a hard core I think
entrepreneurship forced me to do it
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I needed to stay head down
and focused I think you need to have
people in your life who support you and
I have a scale of when you have your
spouse do they outright like hate what
you're doing do they not like it and
kind of like poke jabs at what you're
doing do they support you or they your
cheerleader of those four things you
have to play in the last two you need to
have a spouse or a partner who supports
you they don't have to be your big
chillier they don't have to join you on
your thing they don't have to be a part
of your company they don't they
understand your industry what you're
trying to do but they support and
believe in the thing that you're doing
if you're with somebody who doesn't
support and believe in you I don't think
you can you can last in that
relationship
forget about your business if you're
with someone who doesn't believe in what
you're doing to support you how are you
gonna be with this person for life yeah
I think everyone in this room we all
know what they have to do but then what
happens is some days you don't do that
and then you are disappointed with
yourself then how do you pick yourself
up from that phase and what happens is
most of the time we again keep on
planning that okay we have to do
business and waste more time than
absolutely so how do you balance those
things so whenever I promise myself that
I'm gonna do it I am extremely hard on
myself to go off and do it even really
poorly done so when I came to Boston
when we drove the Boston my goal the
time was I want 30 minutes of cardio
every day we go out in there like 1:30
in the morning or something
I hadn't done my run so what we're gonna
do I got a run that was my run at 1:30
in the morning our '[ __ ] right but I
still did it my god zero helping it I
should have slept like I got zero help
but this is not gonna do anything for
you right everybody's asleep I can't
even put on music or video I'm just like
dying doing this but I feel so good
about myself for doing it
now all if it's if it's borderline like
extreme where this is actually gonna
cause harm
then I'll be super gentle on myself I
wanna say you know what it's okay but I
very rarely get there because most of
the stuff you could actually do like why
can't you just do the thing why can't
you do the thing and then I tie my
esteem to doing the thing whether it's
done well or not just to get it done
right so if you fall off the horse then
like first up just get some version of
it done so you can feel proud for the
effort cuz it was hard and then tomorrow
get up if you had a bad day tomorrow has
to be the greatest day of all time at
least for me if I sucked on one day and
I just let myself down completely then
tomorrow has to be the greatest most
productive day of all time
just to show myself right I'll wake her
up early I'll grind hard with like more
than usual I'll do 30 videos instead of
20 just to prove to myself I'll push
myself really hard just to show that I'm
the kind of person that bounces back
from a setback because you'll have some
you just mentioned the word lazy so
everybody can be lazy right but is that
something you ever valid or if you're
being lazy it's something such a great
sign it means that something needs to
change in your life because everybody
has the ability to be lazy when you're
doing work that you hate and most of the
work in life you hate most jobs you
would suck at and hate
and you'd be really lazy and just do
enough so that you don't get fired and
that's 95 percent of America anyway like
if that's you I can't wait for Friday
I can't wait for Saturday I can't wait
to whatever like your life is broken but
if you're constantly is because your
life is broken and that's a great
relight that doesn't suck that's amazing
and they can fix it yeah very good
taking salary with benefits I also have
a sidekick I'm high performance college
when do you think I can quit my
nine-to-five so this is a personality
question you have to dissect this for
yourself some people need to burn the
boats to go off and do it some people
you need to you need to go to your
boss's office and throw garbage all over
the place and yell at him and and just
you need to do that because you have no
life line to go back
some people can transition out so if
you're a smoker you can do cold turkey
or you can do Nicorette what's gonna
work what is better for your personality
if I was in your situation I would try
to find a way to ramp up my side
business until I had enough money to
survive not to match where I'm at with
my corporate but enough to survive if
I'm surviving by spending fifteen
percent of my time on my business then
if I spend a hundred I mean it happened
right away but I'm not gonna have to
sell my house I don't spend my time now
so I can go and build that up that's
what I would do but either way it's
action I'm doing pretty good with my
youtube channel okay about 17,000
subscribers let's top it up yeah nice I
love it
and with the revenue through YouTube and
I was just curious though the clean and
what point is did you start seeing your
revenue really grow
and should I be focusing on making
merchandise affiliate marketing Anna's
on something else because honestly I'm
looking to make no money that I'm making
now it's been more of a platform for
other ways or should I strive to get a
hundred thousand subscribers so for me
my business my youtube channel started
really taking off when I went daily on
my channel so going from one a week to
one a day made a huge impact and then I
went to two a day then with the three a
day and I'm stuck a three day and I want
to go to a wish I could do eight a day I
don't have enough good contents do that
many but I wish I could you're a channel
not a show when you watch fox or CNN or
whatever there's lots of different shows
on that channel so how often you making
content twice a month but instead of
instead of just keep cranking up average
videos I really make sure that each
video just kicks ass
the more you make the more videos you
make the more you'll learn how to kick
ass the quantity leads to the quality
the more you do the better you'll get
and release in an 80% video every three
days versus 100% video every two every
twice a month or every two months
whatever it is will make a huge
difference for you get used to releasing
80% videos and then learn how to make
80% videos into 85 into 90 into 95 at
higher frequency that's the starting
point
some hacks you can look at how much
YouTube is paying for different
categories go to the Google AdWords tool
type in different keywords see what's
paying higher in your industry some
niches suck like if you're in the recipe
business it sucks nobody's advertising
there if you're in the insurance
business it's awesome for our it's like
making sure it but you have to then have
something to say on it right if what's
your category what do you talked about
with model trains I teach people how to
take the real world of the railroad and
translate the model railroading how to
scratch-build make whatever they want
instead of seven floors of the school
great so maybe like CP Rail model train
is a really expensive keyword do you
have anything that you can say on that
maybe not maybe you don't nothing about
it maybe you hate CP Rail you don't to
make a video on them they suck great but
do you have something you can say on
these high-paying keywords that you can
contribute to the conversation and make
more money so even if it has a little
less views you'll make way more money
from advertising because it's an
important keyword if you're if you're
talking about life insurance because it
pays great on keywords it's like it
doesn't make sense for your niche if you
if your model train blows up you better
have life insurance I don't know like
it's too much of a strategy and you
can't speak authentically about it so
once you've once you start selling out
like that and only chasing the money
your audience will tell and and you'll
feel gross about it like you won't put
your heart into it because you don't
actually do it so you need to create
more content as a starting point for any
of this to work for any advertising for
any newsletter affiliate your own
products any of that stuff you need to
build up a bigger base of people who are
interested in what you're doing and that
comes from creating better content
consistently from there I'm listening to
my customers so yes you can target two
big keywords then I'm listening to my my
audience what do they want do they want
an e course on how to build a model
train do they want affiliate products do
they want to like if you reviewed the
top five Amazon model trains are they
interested in that could you put an
affiliate link in there you're listening
the feedback you test and you listen to
feedback every new video that I make I
love I think it's great but you guys
don't love it that I make I have the
data to show it and so we kill off tons
of series all the time I have to match
with what the audience wants if it's
only me then it's just a hobby
you can make the content you love but if
nobody cares it's just a hobby but if
you're only chasing the market and you
don't care about it you're gonna lose
its ask me that match what you love with
where there's an audience so I've been
looking how do I make a video a week and
how do I make three videos a week I have
a youtube channel I'm still pretty small
have about 4,000 subscribers great men
but I make videos on health and fitness
and mindset can the videos that do the
best are how to jump higher how to
increase your vertical jump and those
get the most views the most traction
bringing the most money so I found
myself doing more and more of those
videos and then more subscribers come in
for people looking how to jump higher
have kind of gotten away from the whole
point of why I made my channel in the
first place which is mindset and fitness
as a whole would you say just keep
Meecham down and continuing to make
videos on vertical jump which I like but
like I don't want that to be my entire
thing so I don't care if you're small or
not like if I stopped like doing the the
top 10 top 10 series if I didn't enjoy
then I would stop it just cold the more
you just stay doing vertical jump videos
you're gonna feel like you've got a job
so why did you leave if you want a job
go get a job you have to bring the other
stuff in you just have to learn how to
get better at doing that stuff and the
only way to get better at doing that
stuff is right go do more a lot of
people putting out content and I don't
do anything from now do anything on
either of those because it's like I'm
passionate about them anymore
but from building out content you're
saying make more videos and you're just
starting out and you're building out
your platforms talk about what you know
edit four five times a day three times a
day like I mean nobody in here is gonna
watch a video on insurance which is why
whenever here consider it yeah well
that's not true people watch a video and
people need to get educated insurance
but you don't care enough about it so
you shouldn't be doing anyway right
great
so go do something else you're looking
for reasons for it not to work instead
of deciding this has to work and then
find solutions as long as you love it I
think people quit way too early on
business ideas and I think people quit
way too late on business ideas I think a
lot of entrepreneurs staying things for
too long and that prevents you from
taking the next jump to something else
here's the thing you have this
great it's gonna disrupt the industry
amazing you're putting work it's not
gonna work it's not happening it's not
that great I mean that happens everybody
newsflash that's what happens every
hunch for there it never happens as fast
as you want but then you quit on it and
then you go off and get a corporate job
and then eventually that thing's gonna
work someone's gonna make it and you're
gonna look at that guy and say should it
mean maybe you needed to wait another
three months or another six months
another eight months you can't put an
arbitrary number on it right after 36
months then I'm out it's do I still love
this thing if you love it then you have
to find a way to keep going and if that
meant I had to take a job full-time or
part-time to figure out how much I
needed like if I knew that I I needed
this much money and I could do that for
t-s-a we got a job to make it that's
what I would do but keep going on this
thing as long as there's hope because
once you completely go corporate and
you're not doing the thing you love
anymore you've lost the hope like you're
never going back to that thing so be
willing to take a step back to then
shoot up
you can't quit as long as you love it
what's that belief nation we are live
here in Pittsburgh just finishing up our
event had a great Solid 3 in a bit hours
we are going to head out for some more
QA but first I want to get some thoughts
some quick thoughts what do you guys
have what did you learn who's going
first renewed hope I love it man take
action over here heard what else stay
focused
baby steps stop perfecting walk up to
more girls there you go what else be
bold
nice don't tire yourself forth the
results what else if you don't do the 2%
you never I just came up with that one
today by the way so I'm glad you liked
that one
glad you liked that one what else more
consistent videos I love it
phears exciting two more strong one
routine
perfection is a momentum killer what a
good one to end on thank you guys okay
[Applause]
[Music]
havoc heads they go Nina I just I'm just
close to my final Instagram of the day
actually probably not of the day to be
honest they'll be more tonight everybody
stories you know what happened while I
post us what happened what happened we
did our first event named in Pittsburgh
how was it it's good
how could have been better how could it
be better look at this crazy pizza how
old it can be [ __ ] it's not good I
don't like barbecues not good I'm so
hungry now okay great first that was
great had a good crowd good group the
exercises seemed to work well the music
figured itself out we've got some good
jokes and good vibe I'm I'm just trying
to think how do I make it better
I think we didn't have enough Q&A time
and so the how it's eleven thirty six
and we finished our last question but I
don't know what to cut to add more Q&A
in like it's a tight what we go through
in three hours is ridiculous it's
ridiculous
hmm but we've already put them all out I
don't know I think there's got to be
think about it well super pumped with
how it went
everybody seemed to really enjoy my
favorite part is always at the end so
I'm looking at there were three people
who I was looking at her a huge chunk of
the time we were like we're not as
engaged as I would have liked they got
the heart but people are like yeah yeah
my god you know really into him then I
think people who weren't doing the
exercises as much that's how you look at
was like oh man come on man I'm trying
to and then and then I got to laugh a
little bit like yeah but still they were
still like really reserved and then it
comes up at the ends like man that was
such a great picture with you and like
really oh so hard so it just blows me
away like you never know you never know
when people are just doing their own
head trying to figure stuff out so um
I'm really happy grateful the
preparation paid off
you lock up work today but but it's
still not good enough right like I think
we need some email to everybody tonight
and say thank you thank you thank you
now how did I suck like I need feedback
on how to make it better because what
exercise what do we cut and what do we
add in I love the I think the Q&A is so
valuable yeah we're gonna think about it
one city down 21 more to go woo really
good so far in this trip
thank you Pittsburgh for the amazing
time there's been a bunch of people who
help me promote this including
[Music]
if you want to know about all the
different prizes that we have available
on this tour check out the video there
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there